>> Sean: JOINING WITH
REACTION TO THE MONOLOGUE AND
BREAKING NEWS, COLUMNIST FROM
"THE HILL" IS JOINING US, JOHN
SOLOMON.
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ
IS WITH US.
AND THERE MIGHT BE A DIRECT
CONFLICT TWO BUT SHA.
I -- CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA.
AS THE F.B.I. DIRECTOR, THE
EFFORTS THEY WERE USING TO
SAVE A FORMER F.B.I. AND A
C.I.A. GUY -- WE HAVEN'T SEEN
HIM IN 11 YEARS -- I AM NOT
I DON'T CARE.
I THINK ANY EFFORT TO SAVE AN
AMERICAN AND ROBERT MUELLER
AND THE F.B.I., I'M ALL FOR
IT.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THE ISSUE BECOMES THE
HYPOCRISY OF THIS.
THIS IS THE SAME RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH THAT THEY ARE USING
IN THE MANAFORT CASE.
AND THEY NEVER POINTED IT OUT.
THAT IS PROBLEM FOR ME.
NOT THE LITTLE LAWS THAT WERE
CITED -- THERE MIGHT BE A
VIOLATION OF LAW BUT I'M GLAD
THEY TRIED HARD TO SAY THIS
GUY.
THAT IS MY NATURAL GUT.
>> YEAH, SURE, THE REAL
QUESTION IS THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION CASE.
DID SOMEONE ASK A FAVOR OF
RUSSIA?
DID TRUMP COLLUDE AND TRY TO
GET A FAVOR?
SIX OR SEVEN BEFORE COLLISION
WAS A TWINKLE IN THE PUBLIC
IMAGINATION, THE F.B.I. ASKED
A FAVOR OF SAME OLIGARCH WHO
IS NOW A CLIENT AND WITNESS
AGAINST PAUL MANAFORT AND
THERE IS NO DISCLOSURE.
WE DON'T KNOW IT, THE COURT
DOESN'T KNOW IT --
>> Sean: DID THE F.B.I. TELL
CONGRESS THEY ASKED THE
OLIGARCH --
>> A GREAT QUESTION.
>> Sean: TO FUND THIS, BY
THE WAY?
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: THEY GOT THE
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH TO PAY $25
MILLION.
ACTUALLY PART OF ME THINKS
IT'S GENIUS.
BUT THEN THEY USE THE SAME GUY
AGAINST MANAFORT AND DON'T
MENTION YOU KNOW THE GUY.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
I TALK TO THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE, HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN FROM THAT TIME.
BILL NELSON AND MIKE ROGERS
WHO SAID THEY WERE NEVER
BRIEFED AND THEY WERE
SURPRISED TO LEARN THE
OPERATION OCCURRED WITHOUT
CONGRESS BEING INFORMED.
>> Sean: PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE LEGALITY OF THIS.
THERE IS A LAW, THE
ANTI-DEFICIENCY ACT TO
PROHIBIT THE GOVERNMENT
ACCEPTING VOLUNTARY SERVICES.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT IS TOTAL B.S.
THIS IS LIKE THE SUPERFLUOUS
IDIOTIC BUREAUCRACY.
I WANT THE AMERICAN SAVED.
I'M NOT FAULTING MUELLER FOR
THAT.
I'M APPLAUDING HIM.
WHICH SURPRISES SOME PEOPLE.
BUT IT'S THE HYPOCRISY.
THEY DIDN'T MENTION THIS IS
THE SAME OLIGARCH IN THE
MANAFORT CASE.
THEY KEPT HIS NAME OUT.
>> YOUR SHOW AND THE GREAT
REPORTING THAT JOHN HAS DONE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THIS IS BUT
ONE CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
THE MUELLER PROBE IS AN ORGY
OF CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
ANY ONE OF THEM INDEPENDENTLY
COULD BE BRUSHED ASIDE BUT
VIEWED IN THE TOTALITY IT
SHOWS HOW CORRUPT AND BIASED
THIS INVESTIGATION IS.
ALSO AN IMPORTANT POINT ON
THIS OLIGARCH DERASPOKA.
SENATOR COTTON ASKED A
QUESTION IN FEBRUARY IF THE
OLIGARCH WAS INVOLVED IN THE
DRAFTING OF THE DOSIER WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
AND CHRISTOPHER WRAY WOULD NOT
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE
VERY OLIGARCH COULD HAVE HAD A
ROLE IN TELLING LIES ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AND WE STILL
DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> Sean: YOU POINT OUT
HYPOCRISY AND THE DOUBLE
STANDARD AND THAT SEEMS TO BE
SOMETHING THEY ARE TRYING TO
HIDE IN THIS CASE.
WHAT OTHER ISSUES SURROUND
THIS THAT YOU DISCOVER?
YOU CITE DOZENS OF PEOPLE
HERE.
OR A DOZEN TO 14 PEOPLE IN THE
ARTICLE AS SOURCES AND WE HAVE
NEVER KNOWN IT BEFORE.
>> THE PEOPLE THAT FIRST
APPROACHED ME WERE ROBERT
MUELLER'S OLD COMRADES AT THE
F.B.I. THAT THOUGHT IT WAS ODD
THEY ASKED THE FAVOR OF THE
OLIGARCH AND HE WAS LEFT OUT.
EVEN THOUGH THERE IS EVIDENCE
CONNECTED TO HIM.
I THINK IF YOU WAKE UP
TOMORROW YOU WILL KNOW WHAT HE
DID WITH RELATIONSHIP TO THE
DOSSIER.
STAY TUNED TOMORROW MORNING.
YOU WILL SOMETHING IMPORTANT
ABOUT THE OLIGARCH.
>> DID HE HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH THE DOSSIER?
>> WE DIDN'T GET ANY ANSWERS
TO THE QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: PEOPLE HAVE ASKED
WHERE YOU HAVE BEEN.
YOU WEREN'T FEELING WELL AND
WE'RE GLAD YOU ARE BACK.
>> WE ARE CLAIMING FOR SPEEDY
RECOVERY OF THE FANTASTIC
FIRST LADY AS WELL.
>> Sean: AMEN.
ABSOLUTELY.
SHE HAS BEEN AMAZING.